tf1 20 heures avec roger gicquel
sidérurgie six mesures pour le nord et
la lorraine pré retraite à 55 ans
concertation locale réactions mitigées
des syndicats sur ce plateau
robert boulin ministre du travail
pétrole la crise en iran provoque une
flambée des prix et une hausse
historique de l'or en france
valéry giscard d'estaing demande
d'accélérer la construction de deux
centrales nucléaires
bonsoir il devrait y avoir un peu plus
d'espoir ou si l'on préfère un peu moins
de désespoir ce soir en lorraine et dans
le nord en délais dans les villes en
tout cas où les régions touchées par la
crise de la sidérurgie ou les durs
nécessité de son sauvetage
la réunion d'aujourd'hui entre robert
boulin ministre du travail à mes côtés
dans ce studio et que nous entendrons
tout à l'heure et les représentants des
cinq syndicats de la métallurgie a
dégagé un certain nombre de points
positifs
de l'aveu même des syndics même si ces
derniers estiment souvent comme le
délégué cfdt que ce bilan positif est
encore trop maigre à cette négociation
les poches du ministre du travail
n'était pas vide comme on l'avait dit
qu'on l'avait supposé précédemment en
particulier sa proposition d'autres
négociations à plusieurs niveaux a
beaucoup intéressé les syndics dans les
jours qui viennent des rencontres avec
le ministre de l'industrie andré giraud
puis avec les industriels des groupes
usinor sacilor sont prévues mais surtout
pour résoudre les problèmes sociaux sur
le terrain entreprise par entreprise et
même cas par cas des comités de bassin
vont être créées composé des
responsables administratifs et des
organisations syndicales
et puis deuxième proposition bien
accueilli la pré retraite à 55 ans dans
la sidérurgie du nord est de la lorraine
en réalité c'est un dispositif en six
points qui a été présenté par robert
boulin les détails d'abord françois go
contre l'industrie les fédérations
syndicales de la métallurgie c'est la
première mesure sans préalable on va
ouvrir le dossier économique et
industriel de l'asie
mise en place de comités de bassin site
par site entreprise par entreprise avec
les syndicats ces comités étudierons
toutes les conséquences des suppressions
d'emplois la situation de chaque
travailleur sera examinée en fonction de
son âge de sa qualification et aussi de
ses aspirations
troisième mesure des aides financières
vont être accordées aux travailleurs qui
quitteront volontairement leur emploi
des primes de départ en quelque sorte
4 l'abaissement de l'âge de la
préretraite on pourra l'obtenir à 55 ans
lieu de 56 ans et trois mois
s'ajoutant à d'autres mesures du même
ordre cela permettra d'éviter 12000
licenciement programme intensif de
formation professionnelle dans la tente
des nouvelles créations d'emplois les
travailleurs licenciés pourront en
bénéficier pour se recycler enfin
poursuite de la concertation après les
travaux des comités de bassin après
l'application du plan boulin le ministre
du travail les syndicats se retrouveront
pour examiner les premiers résultats de
l'opération s'est parlé rapidement tout
à l'heure des réactions des syndicats
j'ai souligné ce qu'ils avaient retenu
de positif dans les propositions de
monsieur boulin mais tous ensemble et
exprime néanmoins un regret très fort le
ministre du travail n'a pas pris tout de
suite l'engagement de suspendre tout
licenciement
je vous propose d'écouter les réactions
enregistrées par françois go les
réactions des syndicats bien sûr avant
d'entendre le ministre du travail
la conclusion la plus positive de cette
réunion c'est que le ministre du travail
a admis que nous rencontrions monsieur
giraud sans aucun préalable c'est à dire
suivant l'expression de paul marc et
l'ict où c'est possible dans cette
discussion
nous pensons que la pression populaire
qui a déjà permis et l'unité des
fédérations d'accrocher cette première
phase des discussions et tout encore
tout à fait
indispensable pour que cette discussion
avec giron permettent de transformer un
certain nombre de décisions et de
projets qui sont tout à fait contestable
le jeu est ouvert maintenant et il est
ouvert je crois grâce à la mobilisation
qui s'est produite en lorraine et dans
le nord pas de calais il faut bien le
dire et c'est je crois le le grave
inconvénient dans cette affaire le
gouvernement n'a pas été capable de
prendre ses responsabilités il y a 6
mois
alors peut-être que maintenant on
arrivera à des solutions mais je
j'ajoute que ces solutions ne pourra
intervenir que si le gouvernement prend
la décision de suspendre toutes les
décisions de licenciements et de
fermetures d'entreprises celles qui les
a prévu nous entendons avec monsieur
giraud une explication quant au fond sur
la politique industrielle sidérurgie ça
n'a pas été fait jusqu'à présent
nous savons que les décisions qui ont
été prises par les groupes ont été pris
sur la base des orientations qui ont été
définies par les pouvoirs publics c'est
à dire par le ministère de l'industrie
qui est maintenant fondamentalement le
patron en quelque sorte la sidérurgie de
voir les dispositions qui ont été prises
par l'état mais il est évident que si
nous ne parvenons pas à convaincre le
ministre l'industrie nous ne
parviendrons pas à convaincre les
dirigeants des groupes sidérurgiques
je suis convaincu que si la pression
revendicative ne s'était pas exercer
comme elle l'a été
nous ne soyons pas aujourd'hui au
ministère du travail donc par conséquent
j'ai bon espoir que la pression
revendicative conduira le gouvernement
reculer sur un certain nombre de choses
tant en matière industrielle quand la
guerre sociale
nous allons naturellement rendre compte
fidèlement de la discussion
nous avons eu ce matin mais en même
temps leur dire que c'est pas le moment
de se démobiliser qu'au contraire il
convient d'intensifier lance initiatives
pour faire pression sur le gouvernement
satin progrès ont été enregistrés en ce
qui concerne d'abord la possibilité
d'avoir une réunion et du giro ministre
d'industrie sur l'ensemble des problèmes
de la politique industrielle nationale
en matière sidérurgie par contre il faut
bien le dire en ce qui concerne l'arrêt
des licenciements qui auraient été de
nature à permettre une certaine
stabilisation dans les bassins dans les
bassins d'emploi le ministre n'est
absolument pas voulu s'engager dans
cette voie là et je pense que ça risque
d'avoir dans les jours à venir d'une
très lourde de conséquences
en lorraine et dans le nord notamment
alors monsieur moulin je remercie
d'abord d'être venu dans ce studio
ma première question va porter sur ce
qui s'est passé aussi aujourd'hui sur le
terrain tandis que vous aviez cette
réunion avec les syndicats parce que sur
place à longwy
les syndicats restent fermes sur leur
position ils disent que la grève du 16
février sera une grande manifestation
est que là ils seront vraiment cette
manifestation sera vraiment puissant
hayange aujourd'hui les mineurs de fer
de sacilor en grève ont occupé les
bureaux de la direction à denain le
directeur et deux cadres d'usinor ont
été retenus dans leurs bureaux ils le
sont encore d'après les dernières
informations
ils ont été retenus dans leurs bureaux
par le personnel d'entretien et puis
autre manifestation il ya eu un
déchargement de wagons de coque sur des
rails des reit d'ailleurs du coq qui
provenait d'allemagne sur des rails à
l'ongle alors voilà ma question pensez
vous que la réunion d'aujourd'hui soient
de nature à ramener le calme
en lorraine parce que c'est le premier
point oui vous savez le gouvernement
comprend très bien l'angoissé des gens
de l'ong hui et de demain pour une
famille qui est menacée de théâtres
privés d'emploi il ya là une situation
tout à fait des astres us le comprendre
le gouvernement est ce que je voudrais
dire ce soir aux gens de demain et de
longwy c'est qu'ils ne seront pas
abandonnés il faut qu'ils en aient
conscience et il faut le dire calmement
et avec une résolution qui est celle du
gouvernement en cette matière
mais il ne faut pas qu'ils se laissent
aller à la violence je dois dire que les
organisations syndicales ne les y pousse
pas et que j'ai trouvé des gens débordés
je ne sais pas mais en tout cas il ne
les y pousse pas ils ont tout à fait
conscience de l'importance et la
difficulté du problème et du désir et du
souci de régler cette affaire mais de la
règle et honnêtement on ne peut pas
faire que nous allons et nous voulons
régler un problème la synergie dans ce
pays ayant les capacités de production
et la compétitivité européenne c'est
cela qu'il faut faire il faut pas qu'on
reconnaît l'air de régler l affaire pour
que dans six mois ou dans un an
recommence à licencier
il faut la régler d'une manière duras
c'est ça l'idée oui mais pourtant il ya
quelques jours on ne croyait pas
beaucoup aux chances
de réussite de cette réunion
d'aujourd'hui de cette pige aux
négociations d'aujourd'hui
alors est ce que est ce que vous pensez
que ce dialogue que vous avez amorcé et
en particulier sur le terrain ce qui est
très important a des chances de réussir
cas par cas entreprise par entreprise
comme vous l'avez pris je le souhaite
très vivement d'abord parce qu' un
dialogue et qu'aujourd'hui n'était pas
question de conclure et de régler
définitivement cette affaire ce qui
était important cette annonce un certain
nombre de choses par exemple dégagement
c sipa du licenciement les avis des gens
à 55 ans qui ont travaillé dur dans les
3,8 à feu continu depuis quinze ou vingt
ans ils ont droit les victimes man u de
retraite et bien une fois ces gens
dégager ça fait plus de dix mille
personnes
nous pourrons voir mieux sur le terrain
et c'est en effet la proposition que
j'ai faite aux syndicats d'avoir des
comités de bassin qui s'occupent un
divinement des familles des cas
particuliers quelqu'un qui à qui on
annonce que il perd son emploi le 1er
juillet 79 et dont on lui dit voici une
usine qui va ouvrir le 1er juillet 80 2
il peut pas être satisfait de la réponse
il faut regarder le problème et apporter
les remèdes appropriés ces comités
devant les moyens d'agir ces comités
auront les moyens d'agir et ils vont
être installés de la manière la plus
rapide je vais en parler naturellement
aux organisations syndicales avec et de
dialogues continus dans un avenir très
proche
je souhaite qu'il soit en place en mars
alors et pourquoi est ce que ce dialogue
nous nous venons de parler ne s'est pas
engagé plutôt bas vous savez il fallait
d'abord
remettre de l'ordre dans la sidérurgie
faut pas oublier que l'été littéralement
faillite il ya eu un effort national
énorme de solidarité bien légitime et
les travailleurs ne sont en rien dans ce
désastre
et ensuite il fallait faire des
propositions au niveau des bassins
aboutir à des propositions concrètes
bref c'est toujours trop tard sûrement
enfin c'est commencer s'est amorcée je
vous répète un certain espoir doit
demeurer et il faut que les gens donnent
un gland oui je le répète à nouveau n'ai
pas le sentiment d'être abandonnés vous
irez vous même sur lequel j'irai sur le
terrain mais j'ai une dernière question
à vous poser
il y à d'autres secteurs en crise est ce
que c'est vraiment inévitable que ses
révisions déchirantes de l'économie
française de 2 de son industrie soit
soit comme sa livrée brutalement et
efface des victimes parmi les
travailleurs qui ne s'y attendent pas du
tout une zone l'air tout à fait surpris
de ce qui se passe ils n'ont pas été
préparées cv prenant l'exemple de la
grande-bretagne savez-vous qui sont
licenciés cinquante six mille personnes
dans la sidérurgie
les allemands et non licenciés 23 1200
c'est une révision déchirante mais il
faut laisser à ces régions leurs
capacités de production
il faut pas que tous les gens ça n'aille
on va créer des entreprises
le fonds spécial d'adaptation
industrielle et droite et des moyens
très importants il faut réanimer le
secteur mais il ya des délais il ya des
problèmes de calendrier qui a des
problèmes humains qui a des problèmes
sociaux alors ça il faut les traiter
avec sérieux mais il faut les traiter
avec courage parce que les travailleurs
de cet endroit ont droit au langage de
la vérité qui est l'avenir de cette
région de ces régions quelle est la
facture nationale de ce dispositif cher
très cher
c'est tout ce que vous pouvez nous dire
pour l'instant merci monsieur le
ministre
écoutons maintenant le premier ministre
raymond barre qui parlait ce matin au
palais des congrès à paris devant les
membres de la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie de paris et puis devant les
patrons de l'île de france aussi est il
a dit que la seule véritable question
urgente actuellement est est de trouver
les moyens pratiques pour que la france
puisse surmonter les difficultés
profondes et durables qui affecte
l'ensemble du monde industrialisé
il a répété que nous n'étions pas au
bout de nos peines que le seul vrai
remède au chômage
c'était la reprise d'une expansion réel
d'une croissance donc saine sans
inflation et sans endettement extérieur
et que l'année 60
neuf sera décisive mais difficile je ne
saurais entretenir l'illusion sur les
délais qui seront nécessaires pour
obtenir une décrue du chômage
à cet égard cette année sera encore
difficile car le processus d'adaptation
de notre économie s'accompagne hélas de
la suppression des emplois excédentaire
la réorganisation de nos entreprises qui
auraient pu s'effectuer comme cela s'est
fait dans d'autres pays en allemagne
fédérale depuis plusieurs années se
concentre hélas au moment le plus
difficile de notre conjoncture et de la
conjoncture internationale
mais je voudrais vous dire qu'une
stratégie qui viserait à maintenir des
emplois dans des conditions
artificielles loin de résoudre le
problème du chômage ne servirait qu'à la
graver dernières nouvelles économiques
de la journée rené monory
le ministre de l'économie a mis en place
ce matin jury composé de quatorze chefs
d'entreprises chargés de sélectionner
des candidats tenté par la reprise et le
redressement d'entreprises saines mais
en difficulté
ces futurs gestionnaires devront avoir
apporté la preuve bien sûr de leurs
qualités professionnelles et s'ils n'ont
pas les moyens financiers nécessaires
pour redresser telle ou telle entreprise
ils pourront recevoir un prêt d'honneur
sur un fonds doté actuellement de 20
millions de francs
à téhéran dans les bars des grands
hôtels on refuse désormais de vous
vendre de l'alcool
pas d'alcool en république islamique
vous répond le barman
c'est peut-être un des signes qui
montrent qu'on prend au sérieux le
gouvernement provisoire formé par
l'ayatollah khomeiny le premier ministre
officiel monsieur bakhtiar continue lui
à faire face devant le parlement
il a répété que son objectif c'était une
démocratie pour tout le monde et pas
pour quelques-uns et qu'il ne s'agissait
pas de remplacer la dictature passé et
ses polices par de nouveaux problèmes du
même genre ce matin plus de cent mille
personnes ont célébré la proclamation du
gouvernement provisoire n'y a pas eu
d'incident mais l'aviation iranienne a
fait une démonstration sur laquelle on
s'interroge
c'était un vol en formation au dessus
des manifestants les partisans de
l'ayatollah organise en ce moment des
milices populaires de nouvelles grandes
manifestations sont prévues pour demain
mais pendant ce temps là
l'économie iranienne est à bout de
souffle et du coup la tension sur le
marché mondial du pétrole et dans les
principaux pays consommateurs amérique
en trop jusqu'à présent on se disait que
l'iran serait bien obligée force est de
rétablir très vite sa production de
pétrole pour se procurer des devises
et aujourd'hui on en est moins sûr il a
suffi que l'ayatollah laisse entendre
qu'ils voulaient réduire les livraisons
iranienne de 40% pour que la spéculation
se déchaînent y compris sur le marché de
l'or en france même s'il n'y a pas de
danger de pénurie dit on le gouvernement
s'inquiète tout de même de la hausse du
prix du brut et l'augmentation des
carburants dans huit jours le 15 février
pourrait dépasser les 5 centimes
envisagé sur le litre de super et puis à
plus long terme la sécurité de nos
approvisionnements est tout de même en
cause et ça se complique quand on veut
réduire les dépenses d'énergie et qu'en
même temps on constate que la
consommation continue continue à
augmenter plus vite que les prévisions
faites jusqu'à l'horizon 85 c'est tout
cela qui a provoqué la réunion d'un
conseil restreint à l'elysée aujourd'hui
et le président de la république a
demandé alors que soit accéléré le
programme d'équipement électro nucléaire
de la france en insistant pour que les
centrales prévues dans les régions dont
nous parlions tout à l'heure le nord et
la lorraine
plus exactement à cattenom
lorraine et à gravelines dans le nord
soit équipé dans les délais les plus
rapides
compte tenu a ajouté le président des
effets attendus sur les implantations
industrielles et les créations d'emplois
de la construction de ces centrales dans
ces régions avec emmanuel de la taille
le problème de l'évolution immédiate des
prix du pétrole
et revoilà le pétrole la fermeture de
l'iran ses conséquences à terme sur
l'approvisionnement mondial
la tendance immédiate à la hausse du
brut ont mobilisé le gouvernement pour
trouver des parades rapide mais aussi
renforcer notre programme d'indépendance
énergétique pour 85 à l'origine de cette
mini crise du pétrole le blocage du brut
iranien
déjà maintenant pour 3 mois minimum sans
qu'on sache quand la production
repartira certes l'iran deuxième
exportateur ne fournit que 8 % de notre
consommation et nous avons en stock
l'équivalent de trois ans de pétrole
iranien
mais la rupture se répercute sur une
demande mondiale qui se gonflent avec
l'hiver et la reprise économique
les intérêts et la politique s'en mêle
ainsi l'arabie qui avait ouvert un
robinet de secours aux compenser l'iran
envisage non seulement un relèvement de
ses tarifs mais une limitation de ses
services pour faire pression sur la
politique américaine au moyen-orient
autant de remous qui provoquent de
grandes manoeuvres internationale une
flambée des prix à rotterdam des
difficultés pour les professionnels en
france aidé à coup sûr le dollar et l'or
problème urgent pour la france à combien
fixe et l'augmentation des carburants le
15 février
on prévoyait environ 5 centimes sur le
super en fonction des housses de l'opep
du dollar et des marges des pompistes
comme en belgique le relèvement pourrait
être plus élevée notamment pour le fioul
domestique afin d'assurer un
approvisionnement régulier et suivre la
tendance des tarifs sans aller trop fort
pour ne pas bousculer les indices des
prix
le fardeau du pétrole n'a pas fini de
peser sur l'économie et l'emploi quand
on constate en plus que c'est
essentiellement par le freinage de la
croissance facteur de chômage que nous
avons jusqu'ici limiter la facture d'où
la relance par le président de la
république du programme nucléaire en
attendant la spéculation rebondi partout
c'est le thermomètre des spéculations
qu'aspire la terrine yens 33 mille
francs le kilo c'est le record absolu
l'origine de cette fièvre c'est aux
états unis qu'il faut la chercher
les américains n'ont le droit d'acheter
de l'or que depuis peu mais ils ont
rattrapé leur retard
aujourd'hui il spécule sur l'or comme
ils le faisaient sur les autres matières
premières l'argent le sucre le café ou
encore le cuivre qui a atteint de ses
plus hauts niveaux depuis quatre ans et
demi
ils achètent à tour de bras comme si les
matières premières risque est de faire
défaut demain
quitte à regret en bloc si l'horizon
économique et politique s'éclaircit
paradoxalement à paris le marché reste
très calme et les cours sont plus
faibles qu'ailleurs les spéculateurs
français n'achètent plus d'or depuis la
loi sur les plus values qui a créé une
taxe de 4 % sur les revend alors à paris
en profite plutôt des cours record
atteint ailleurs de 147 dollars l'once
hier soir de chicago pour vent
officiellement il est interdit de faire
sortir le métal jaune de france mais
comme les américains achètent et que les
français vendent
on est bien obligé de se poser une
question existe-t-il une filière
parallèle pour faire sortir le métal
jaune de france sont imposés jean pierre
pernaut les autres nouvelles de ce
journal oui d'abord à l'étranger on
parle de trouble assez important au
zaïre dans la banlieue de kinshasa et à
la demande du gouvernement zaïrois des
commandos de parachutistes belges
s'apprête à partir au zaïre sans doute
la semaine prochaine pour dit on à
bruxelles pas officiellement on le dit
quand même pour protéger les trente
mille ressortissants belges qui se
trouvent en ce moment à kinshasa en tout
cas un bataillon a été mis un bataillon
de para-commandos a été mis en état d'
alerte près de namur et ce prochain
départ d
des militaires belges au zaïre a été
annoncée officiellement par le ministre
belge des affaires étrangères on aura
sans doute des précisions à 23 heures la
condamnation à mort d'ali buteau ancien
premier ministre du pakistan confirmé
par la haute cour de justice de ce pays
reconnu coupable d'avoir ordonné le
meurtre d'un de ses adversaires
politiques
ali bhutto pourraient être pendus thank
you ping est arrivé à tokyo pour une
visite de trois jours
il souffre d'une petite grippe est le
numéro 2 chinois commencera seulement
ces entretiens politiques demain avec
les dirigeants japonais
en ce qui concerne son voyage de neuf
jours aux états unis qu'il a terminé
hier soir monsieur thank you ping a dit
que le succès avait été complet et
pendant ce temps là on continue de voir
des choses étonnantes à pékin un millier
de chinois et quelques européens suivent
vous le voyez des cours de danse tout
près de la place tiananmen
déjà le soir du réveillon des diplomates
avaient dans celle visco vous vous en
souvenez j'ajoute que parmi les autres
changements en chine
la publicité banni depuis 20 ans a fait
sa réapparition dans un journal de
shanghai avec des messages pour un
western américain pour coca cola bien
sûr et pour une crème contre le
vieillissement de la peau en france
entre trois et dix mille salariés de
l'edf ont manifesté ce matin à paris
objectif de la cgt la cfdt défendre la
notion de service public à edf autre
rassemblement celui de 250 professeurs
d'école normale ils protestent contre
les 450 disparitions de postes prévues
pour la rentrée prochaine
pour les représentants de la fédération
de l'éducation nationale cela menace
l'existence de certaines écoles normales
les obsèques du gendarme mocaer tué d'un
coup de couteau dans le métro à paris la
semaine dernière ont eu lieu en fin de
matinée à la caserne de gendarmerie
mobile d'aubervilliers il y avait bien
sûr toute sa famille ses collègues
et puis le ministre de la défense yvon
bourges et le directeur de la
gendarmerie qui étaient venus lui rendre
un dernier hommage ils ont tous les deux
souligné leur indignation après cet
assassinat qui a provoqué une très forte
émotion dans toute la france une bande
de voyous a détruit 250 parcs m la nuit
dernière à paris six jeunes gens ont été
arrêtés ils sont connus par les services
de police que militants anarchistes ou
simple voleur déjà condamné il voulait
prendre l'argent des parcs m
et il affirme n'avoir aucune motivation
politique monseigneur poupart évêque
auxiliaire du cardinal marty il devient
d'être nommé à ce poste par le pape jean
paul ii
monseigneur poupart conserve sa charge
directeur à l'institut catholique de
paris
mes obsèques de notre confrère lucien
barnier auront lieu demain paris elles
se dérouleront à 13h45 à notre dame de
lorette autre chose développer
l'enseignement musical en france c'est
l'objectif du gouvernement
parmi les mesures annoncées ce matin par
jean philippe lecat la création en
octobre prochain d'un conservatoire
national supérieur de musique à lyon
dans l'actualité littéraire maintenant
sachez que le 20e prix littré a été
attribué aujourd'hui le lauréat et guy
marie vianney pour l'ergot de seigle aux
nouvelles éditions bodinière zizanie au
lycée de mirepoix en ariège
les lycéens étaient en grève ils
réclament tout simplement que les cours
soient facultatif que l'accès au dortoir
soit libre toute la journée et que les
garçons puissent accéder librement au
dortoir des filles
le proviseur a préféré fermer le lycée
du sport maintenant avec le ski perrine
pellen n'est que 5e du slalom géant de
berchtesgaden comptant pour la coupe du
monde première l'allemande kinshofer
devant sa compatriote iren et pleut and
mary mother est troisième et puis un mot
des vacances elle commence ce soir pour
la première zone celle des parisiens
plus d'un milieu dans d'un million
d'entre eux vont partir vers la montagne
et la direction des routes leur
conseille de ne pas partir avant 9
heures du matin entre 3 et 9 heures
cette nuit la circulation pourrait être
très très chargé alors le temps
justement pour ces départs et puis pour
les autres pour ceux qui ne partent pas
les températures sont restées clémente
pour un mois de février aujourd'hui et
même franchement agréable dans le midi
demain matin le temps sera encore froid
et brumeux dans l'est le nord est et le
nord
ensuite dans ces régions il pleuvra où
il y aura quelques chutes de neige sur
le reste de la france est bien le temps
sera doux couvert et pluvieux et les
vents seront assez fort près de
l'atlantique et de la manche
un temps qui va s'améliorant et va
peut-être vers le printemps qui sait
ariane dans la mythologie c'est la ds
qui est date taizé à sortir du
labyrinthe du minotaure en lui donnant
un fil le fil d'ariane
or l'europe qui fait aussi partie de la
mythologie même des temps modernes
c'était dans le domaine spatial enfoncez
elle aussi dans un labyrinthe c'est à
dire une succession de problèmes
politiques sans issue en 71 7 et la
faillite de l'europe spatiale
tout simplement parce que les terres
incapable de construire sa fusée mais
aujourd'hui il
semblerait qu'on ait trouvé un fil
d'ariane pour l'europe de l'espace avec
la fusée baptisée justement ariane cet
engin de trois étages sera capable de
rivaliser avec les fusées américaines
qui sont actuellement en position de
suprématie qu est depuis hier à rien
n'est plus seulement un projet ce que
les journalistes ont vu en guyane au
centre spatial de kourou
c'est une sorte de modèle d'essai
grandeur nature qui porte déjà tous les
espoirs des experts tf1 bien sûr étaient
sur place
ariane c'est un programme de 4 milliards
300 millions c'est très cher mais à ce
qu'on dit c'est le prix de
l'indépendance
michel chevalet courroux hier au début
de l'après-midi sur ce qui doit devenir
le cap kennedy de l'europe signer à ce
photographe journaliste tous les
ingénieurs et techniciens sont venus
voir la fusée
à 15h30 lentement la tour se retirer à
ariane apparaît dans la splendeur de ses
trois étages telle qu'elle sera lancé
avant la fin de l'année ce n'est pas
encore la vraie fusée mais un modèle
destiné à tester les équipements au sol
bref un grand jour pour l'europe
mais attention tout le monde se souvient
tous les ingénieurs tous les techniciens
du centre spatial guyanais nous y sommes
actuellement se souviennent de ce qui
s'est passé ici même à l'endroit où vous
voyez des fusées ariane de ce qui s'est
passé
le 5 décembre 1971
ce jour là la première fusée européenne
europa 2 a fini dans un magnifique feu
d'artifice
le résultat est bien vous le voyez sur
ces images ces deux étages de fusées
attendent chez un ferrailleur à côté de
kourou que des acheteurs viennent alors
qu'à l'époque ces deux étages de fusée
avait coûté 1 milliard 200 millions de
francs aujourd'hui on voulait brade les
deux pour 50000 francs et avec en prime
et bien tout un lot d'ordinateurs et
tuyauterie pour ses pulls finalement
quoi faire ariane c'est donc un triple
paris d'abord un pari technique
c'est-à-dire que l'on réussira ensuite
un pari économique à savoir que les
européens vont construire et vendre des
fusées rivalisant avec la navette
américaine
enfin paris politiques ou 4 milliards
300 millions de francs
c'est à se demander si les européens
n'ont pas les yeux plus grands que le
ventre
je crois pas je cautionne sur n'examine
toute l'histoire courte en disant des
satellites de télécommunications de de
télévision directe de métrologie
c'est absolument évident que même on y
apprendrait besoin de des lances comment
voulez-vous que l'iran fabrique les
lanceurs les deux satellites de
télécommunications et après demande aux
américains avec lequel nous avons une
concurrence féroce lancé moi ça s'il
vous plaît c'est absolument inconcevable
nous devons avoir notre moyens
indépendants
ici à kourou on va donc se hâter
lentement ne prendre aucun risque car
ariane et la fusée de la dernière chance
et de ce qu'on demande c'est qu'à ce
prix là ça fonctionne enfin pour le
dernier journal bruno masure vers 23h30
merci d'avoir écouté ce journal merci de
votre attention